tras 11 semanas sin gobierno túnez
vuelve a tener uno liderado por nagla
wood en la primera mujer del mundo árabe
en ocupar este cargo se apoya en varias
personas cercanas al presidente caixa y
es el banquero samir said fue nombrado
ministro de economía y planificación
el abogado taufic charafedín vuelve al
ministerio del interior que ocupó entre
septiembre de 2020 y enero de 2021
durante la investidura puig d´en anunció
los retos futuros
belden uno de los objetivos más
importantes de la historia es combatir
la corrupción que se extiende cada vez
más día a día y conduce a una pérdida de
confianza en cualquier intento de
reforma radical y real la flamante
primer ministra recibe un país con una
economía duramente golpeada por la
pandemia de kobe 19 y la corrupción
endémica
pero también deberá tranquilizar a una
comunidad internacional y aun fm y
preocupado para el nuevo equipo los
retos son grandes pero sus prerrogativas
son muy limitadas desde el 25 de julio
el jefe de estado- caixa jet se ha
autoconcedido prácticamente todos los
poderes suspendió el parlamento anunció
su intención de crear una comisión para
modificarla y ahora está legislando por
decreto durante la ceremonia de ayer
volvió a justificar sus acciones
el estrés ya no queremos quedarnos a la
sombra de medidas excepcionales pero
permaneceremos a su sombra mientras
exista un peligro inminente en el
parlamento y en otras instituciones
wafi a tener almohadas seattle o foro
para sus opositores y varias ongs esto
no es más que un golpe de estado eso es
lo que denunciaron el domingo al menos
6.000 personas que salieron a las calles
de la capital en contra de la toma de
poder de esta jet